c'est un sentiment partagé par beaucoup
de gens aujourd'hui on est dans une
période la période la plus dure de cette
crise
d'abord il ya l'accumulation c'est notre
cinquième semaine d'une dérive cinquième
semaine confinement alors il ya des gens
qui sont tannés à des gens qui n'en
peuvent plus et c'est bon gossas et
hiolle le nombre de morts qui
s'accumulent québec par exemple
aujourd'hui c'est la plus grosse
augmentation donc 630 morts
actuellement 6 130 décès on a eu mille
cas de plus par rapport à hier les
hospitalisations ça va c'est en dessous
du seuil de 7% qui est un pull à la
cible avec 1018 personnes
il ya même moins de gens aux soins
intensifs aujourd'hui qu'il n'y en avait
hier mais c'est les gens qui meurent
essentiellement dans les sièges à celle
des docteurs car vice président de
l'association des médecins microbiologie
c'est avec le dr weiss bonsoir j'ai fait
sortir quelques chiffres bien sûr la
crise n'est pas terminée à la fois
prendre ça avec des reculs des pincettes
mais le tout par un million d'habitants
le taux de décès par un million
d'habitants voyez le québec qui est
quand même assez élevé on s'éloigne de
dd tous les plus bas de l'allemagne qui
est 46 et des autres pays alors quelques
veaux vu la thur était c'est sûr qu'au
québec on est en train d'avoir un
problème au niveau des chs ld de nos
aînés on est à peu près 23 pour cent de
la population canadienne on a fait un
pour cent des décès on augmente encore
de façon soutenue dans nos décès si on
se compare aux autres programmes
donc on a définitivement un problème qui
plus est geek ailleurs on en a déjà dit
et c'est pour ça qu'on en dise et ben on
était né il y en a encore à monter puis
après ça il ya un plateau faut pas
oublier qu'on a un sommet puis à plateau
alors ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point oui on est tirés pire
entre guillemets que dans les autres
provinces canadiennes
on n'est quand même pas l'italie on
n'est quand même pas l'espagne on n'est
quand même pas la france qui m'a avec
des taux ajusté en inde et au beaucoup
plus bas et il ya des pays en europe
auxquelles on pourrait se comparer par
exemple la suisse ou la belgique quand
des populations on va dire relativement
similaire mais qui font moins bien que
le québec en termes de décès bien des
pays par contre comme d'autres pays dans
le monde comme la nouvelle zélande
l'autriche
israël qui est en des populations si
similaires au québec mais qui font mieux
et on avait donné l'exemple du portugal
aussi qui a une population un peu plus
grande que le québec mais qui fait
relativement mieux aussi
donc on n'est certainement pas les
meilleurs mais on n'est certainement pas
les pires non plus il faut quand même
pas non plus ce tir est un conte moment
d'un pied en se disant bien regarder si
rien ne fonctionne
et des choses qui fonctionnent mais
malheureusement on est pris avec une
situation très difficile dans un réseau
de traite de 200 de soins prolongés de
relance pour les personnes âgées ou en a
on est on est littéralement où il ya
densité de population âgée plus grande
qu'ailleurs au pays
donc dans ces centres elle laisse en
plus nombreux au québec qu'ailleurs au
pays
donc ça explique que ces données là par
ailleurs je veux quand même vous
entendre sur cet appel qui a été fait
hier par monsieur legault à vos
collègues médecins spécialistes vous en
êtes dans votre réflexion là dessus mais
ça c'est un avis très personnel d'abord
une concerne à moi et ma spécialité
quand vous êtes là vie non pas moi mais
je parle je parle pas de moi je pardonne
et des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
on et 220 on a répondu à l'appel depuis
très longtemps travaillé sans arrêt par
tous mes collègues de beaucoup de
spécialités sont aussi au front comme
noé travaille extrêmement fort il faut
saluer tous mes collègues urgentologue
intensiviste nos malheurs cardiologue et
vous savez j'ai beaucoup de mes
collègues qui se sont portés volontaires
à nous aider j'étais sur des étages avec
mon collègue rhumatologues et à colette
cardiologue et y résident en orl qui
vous nous aidez donc ce que je veux dire
c'est que il ya déjà une forme d'un très
important de la part des médecins
spécialistes
beaucoup de nous caler dans les
spécialités chirurgicales sans vous nous
aidez nous on est disponible et en est
là encore pour aider pour aller partout
vous avez vu que ya plus de 1000
spécialistes qui ont répondu en 24
heures pour aller dans les ca c'est
celle des
vous savez en avant d'être médecin
spécialiste en est médecin et avant
d'être médecin on est tout simplement
des simples citoyens veulent aider son
prochain
alors on est là pour aider le plus
possible vous savez la raison pour
laquelle on m'a demandé pourquoi je suis
rentré en médecine past et surtout pour
aider les gens vous savez moi je voulais
aller dans une spécialité dans une
domaine plus scientifique plus en
mathématiques mois en physique mais
j'avais aucun intérêt parce qu'il y
avait aucun intérêt là dedans je n'ai
rien contre les mathématiciens on a
compris c'est juste qu'il n'y avait pas
la comédie vous avez pu me dire aussi
que j'aurais pu être historien parce que
votre goût de l'histoire revient
plusieurs reprises je vous pose deux
questions du public dr vaches v6 de
concentré en une qui revient vraiment
beaucoup et c'est les personnes âgées
qui nous écrivent en dix ans et par
exemple on va prendre cette question mon
conjoint 80 agents des 73
nous avons fait l'ascension du volcan
stromboli nous pratiquons le vélo le
jogging nous ne souffrons d'aucune
maladie chronique
en quoi sommes nous plus à risque des
gens de 50 ans il ya beaucoup de gens
âgés qui nous écrivaient arrêtez de nous
parler nous comme si on allait mourir
demain il ya déjà 13 enfants
est-ce qu'ils sont bons mais je vous
écoute à écouter la première chose si
vous avez vous avez réussi à remonter le
stromboli à 80 ans j'espère que je vais
être temps que vous avez donc en effet
vous êtes certainement en forme et c'est
bravo mais il n'empêche peu plus vous
êtes âgé plus le risque d'avoir des
complications d'aller aux soins
intensifs et de mourir augmente et on a
vu des personnes qui avaient tout
simplement lâche comme un facteur de
risque
il ya peut-être des explications qui
ressemble au point de vue de récepteurs
pour le virus au niveau pulmonaire
peut-être qu'il ya certains récepteurs
et c'est une théorie qui commence
ils sont plus nombreux cantons on
devient plus âgés et ça permet donc au
virus de s'attacher plus facilement aux
cellules par vos poumons et de créer des
problèmes plus importants
il ya aussi cet aspect de l'immunité
plus on est âgé moins notre système
immunitaire est prêt à apprendre des
nouveautés et donc d'adaptation
d'adaptabilité
donc c'est tout simplement une question
de risque alors et kt et oui
je sais que ça peut être plein de rester
en confinement 80 ans mais on veut on
veut vous garder en santé longtemps pour
vous puissiez montée stromboli à 85 ans
voilà c'est bien dit on a beaucoup parlé
question 2 2 des personnes un symptôme
atik mais développe-t-elle des anticorps
quand même
oui bien sûr ça veut pas dire que parce
que vous êtes asymptomatiques que vous
n'allez pas avoir d'anticorps tout à
fait vous allez développer des anticorps
comme si vous aviez été malade
donc le fait d'avoir été en contact avec
le virus va vous mettre et c'est comme
ça que lorsqu'on aura des tests
sérologiques ça va devenir très utile
pour savoir qui a fait la fiction dans
une population sans avoir été malade
donc la question numéro 4 elle revient
jeu désolé si je voulais déjà posé dr
mais avec l'arrivée du beau temps et de
la chaleur qu'elles sont les restes de
contamination dans les points d'eau
naturels ou les piscines etc dans
l'abside et dans l'eau c'est pas
vraiment un problème c'est pas une
transmission
la question c'est que si vous êtes tout
seul ici n'y aura aucun problème c'est
les gens autour de vous qui risque de
vous contaminer donc l'eau n'est pas un
vecteur de transmission de ce virus là
mais de s'assembler autour de points
d'eau ça pourrait devenir un problème
voilà on s'est préparé non pas de
problème à les faire du kayak sur votre
l'acte ou sommes là et si ces votes la
balle est dans votre piscine si vous
êtes tout seul mais faut pas vous allez
dans une piscine municipale là où il y
aurait beaucoup de monde très bien et
puis une question d'un enfant sasha 7
ans notre système peut-il lutter de man
tilt contre deux virus différents en
même temps alors la réponse simple c'est
oui même contre +22 virus
il faut savoir que notre système tous
les jours sont ils luttent en termes d'
immunité contre toutes sortes de choses
qui sont dans notre environnement
tous les jours tous les humains sur la
terre on va être en contact avec toutes
sortes de virus toutes sortes de
microbes toutes sortes de bactéries
toutes sortes d'alertés vous savez des
pollens et tout ça et notre système
immunitaire va pouvoir s'adapter à tous
ses ennemis en même temps donc oui notre
système immunitaire est capable de
lutter contre le virus en même temps la
seule chose qu'il faut savoir c'est que
souvent lorsqu'on a deux virus qui
essaient de nous affecter
il va y avoir une compétition un peu
défendre
pour savoir qui va avoir la priorité
d'infecter si vous voulez l'autre en
tant qu elle que ça dr weiss merci
beaucoup
bonne soirée continuez votre travail
extraordinaire à l'hôpital on se reparle
merci ok bonne soirée par mois voir